good
morning Millennials welcome to the
morning toast or as this week's case the
morning matzo we are very excited to be
here Jackie my normal co-hosts usually
she's not here because she's moving
today she's very excited so well she
said she couldn't be here she's really
excited to be getting out of her
apartment and well on said she's not
here I'm really excited to have like a
safe space for myself to talk about
Taylor Swift as much as I want save
space because snitches here if you guys
so don't stick to your new toaster
stitches our little sister don't ask
when we call the snitch it's like a long
story and honestly I don't really know
the genesis of it and she's just gonna
be here to Khoa says me obviously
deliver the fast five but we've kind of
centralized some of the topics around
Taylor Swift just cuz like we are the
biggest chuckle I would say I'm the
biggest telogen family family fan in the
family and you're like number like one
and a half okay I wasn't saying it to is
meeting but one and a half I'll take and
like the Jackie's always over here like
claiming to be a Taylor Swift it's not
but she's always a talking [ __ ] you know
like it's like then she like goes to the
rep tour I like him pretends that she's
like having the best time of her life
screaming every song but then you come
on here and talk [ __ ] about her publicly
ya know and it's like not gonna fly I
firmly believe that like part of being a
good stan is like being able to call
people out like when they need it like
just blindly loving someone isn't always
healthy right but calling her a piece of
[ __ ] isn't being critical Margo I
couldn't agree more and like okay I'm a
good tamp Sam like I can agree that like
what Taylor did with the whole kami
Connie thing like was shady I agree and
I love him so much and it pains me to
say but like she was wrong like she lied
and then lied so she lied in them but
Jackie was being so aggressive with me
yesterday like you don't understand I
literally almost had tears in my eyes
like I was getting so defensive and like
I wasn't doing a good like job of
articulating my feelings cause like I
understand Jackie's so articulate and
like she can make a point even if it's
like the most wrong point or yeah so I'm
just like okay okay no yeah I would
never want to argue with Jackie
especially like on sometimes though I
would say this is gonna be just like I
mean there's so much going on in the
world of Taylor Swift and we'll do what
we're gonna do is there's never anything
going on in the world right so it's like
a big day for us it's a huge day for us
in tomorrow's when the Mattei that tasty
now it's a bigger dick but bigger day
for us it's just it's also exciting it's
also exciting I'm just so happy she's
back to like booking her best meet you
oh my god like her hair is in check what
makeup and her lip color is in check and
that is the most important it's just
it's all so good and we're gonna jump
right in we're gonna do past five I have
two of the stories are Taylor Swift
focused but that is what it is if you're
on a Taylor Swift fan just like get
ready to convert yeah get ready to
convert we're about to turn in to turn
you into some Swifties but before we do
that let's talk about what we're doing
tonight oh yeah do I'm taking do it
we're going to see wicked
we're going to see what could for a
million reasons one I haven't seen it
since I was a kid - I don't even
remember the plot - I'm so head over
heels in love with the soundtrack that
like I can't believe I haven't seen it
like with a margarita in my hand oh yeah
we can when we were 12 yeah not even and
then three the girl who plays wicked a
fraternity Alpha boy face oh yeah she is
her run ends in like two weeks and she
follows me on Instagram and I got bendy
I mean her so like I wanted to see her
yeah and I think we're gonna go
backstage maybe like get our face
painted green oh my god I would die I
would die too so just like we have that
to look forward to that's very exciting
I'm actually very excited I don't know
how I'm gonna like oh it's very exciting
you're very excited yeah okay you just
said it like are you like this is so
exciting
no he's how big was I love I love that
nobody's like what excites me excitement
okay I'm looking forward to it meet you
it's gonna be just like such a gradual
time I don't know how I'm not gonna like
a belt out like people are gonna yell at
me cuz like yeah I know you're gonna be
rolling like even when I saw Dr Vance
and I only knew like the one song waving
through a window and I still was like
waving like you're gonna be like in the
chair like with your hand sure I don't
have an aisle seat so I can just like
get some extra like movement for my
self-expression where you need it you
need to do your art totally it's just
gonna be it's gonna be great like I
usually I don't love going to the
theater to get there it's annoying to
get there but this is should we get
dinner before or after you think the
shows of seven four shows are long
there's an intermission are you starving
we can't have any of the snacks cuz
they're not come by a crew because it's
Passover okay so we'll go somewhere
before
yeah Oh me and TPG went to the palm yeah
before we went - okay let's do that
oh yeah whatever sorry I'm just making
plans in my head but before we have the
night of our lives we do have to deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast so without
further ado let's jump right in snitch
and the first story is one that I just
couldn't not talk about and we have a
picture if you're watching like Taylor
Swift is picture perfect in pastel gown
at the time 100 gala see pics and her
performance Taylor Swift is a real
princess according to Entertainment
Tonight the you belong with me singer
stepped out in a breathtaking pastel
gown to attend the 2019 time 100 gala at
Lincoln Center in New York City on
Tuesday the Grammy winner looked divine
in a peach and yellow strapless J
Mendell gown with floral embroidery and
billowing sleeves she paired the design
with the yellow got with yellow Chloe
Gosselin heels and Lorraine Schwartz
jewelry her makeup looked flawless
consisting of sparkly peach eye shadow
pink blush and a soft pink glossy lip
her hair was it a messy yet elegant updo
and wore a metal floral headband and I
just think it's important to know she
took the sleeves off for her performance
it was like a whole other dress it
wasn't a dress I wasn't crazy about the
sleeves to begin with it no I was crazy
about the sleeves first of all cuz they
were such a fashion moment yeah but also
they were so love story like so she was
Juliet in the town so was the the
freaking the head thing oh my gosh and
she played love story like she was
playing with us she was playing with us
at first when I was watching I thought
that she was gonna do a song from each
album cuz she at first we're watching
the first I was just like seeing like
updates via like Twitter steamy Swifties
and then like if you just checked the
hashtag up hashtag Taylor Swift and then
once you finally decided to answer my
texts I'm sorry because I was on my
phone watching a live stream and I
didn't want to [ __ ] answer your texts
and miss Eliza no I understand but I had
to let you know that that girl from pose
on Fox was live-streaming the whole
thing right right right
so then I got that text and then I was
watching and then her life rose her life
rose but it was over yeah so she did but
I just have one controversial thing to
say no matter what or how Taylor sings
it I will always hate shake it off okay
same no like I can't even bear you know
what when it first came out like we
loved it and I loved the music video no
we love to the whole thing but it was
like the the overplaying of it is what
ruins songs like we're gonna get there
with thank you next you think yeah yeah
maybe but for some reason shake it off
just like when I hear that beat I'm like
oh no saben also I don't like it because
it brings out all like the fake fans
like the bandwagon errs who only know
that song from the radio by the way yeah
the room there a time when I'm sure the
[ __ ] just like screaming to shake it
off it's like you don't know the words
to love stories but you know the words
to shake it off yeah actually also love
delicate acoustically she did that with
me no I mean she just when she is just
on a stage with a guitar or the piano
like there's nothing more special yeah I
love when she's on the piano like New
Year's Day New Year's Day the the music
is so beautiful yeah and we have to tell
you that obviously I should
we should also talk about the theory
going around
she said I want her midnight so the line
in New York says I want your Midnight's
and she says that it's in the quarter so
she says it like five or six times in
the song and of the clip from last night
in one moment it appears like she says I
want her Midnight's and obviously
there's a big theory that Taylor is is
gay and it's called the Geller Swift and
I'd like love that and I would love if
she was gay I don't know if like a part
of me just wants to believe it cuz I
would love it like my queen was lesbian
but I don't think that it is true but
she did say it she did say and there are
a lot of thing if you play devil's
advocate when she when she said those
lines later on it sounded like her but
it was definitely your cuz it was
breathy so she could have just been like
extremely breathy and it could have just
sounded like her or she was dropping a
bit of an easter egg I don't know it's
like I if Taylor was gay like she
doesn't have to tell us like she's not
been the type of person to ever like
give us official updates in her personal
life it's true she values her privacy so
I don't people are thinking that this
count dad is like to her coming out I'm
like that is so dumb like she would
never do that
oh so like why would you come out at
midnight Eastern right totally she
values her privacy too much and I value
that for her and I would never demand
her come out as anything me neither
other than what she is I agree
no and I just I think there's no way
that it's not gonna be anything but
music of course like everyone's like if
being a fashion line like please it's
called merch no that's so stupid
but that dress like I legitimately I
can't buy it and that if I could it
would be like thirty thousand dollars
but I got the honey browser maybe I can
get a coupon code the honey browser do
you have it yes because I'm always
broken anything to save money the
toasters tell me about it it is the
greatest thing and they're now a partner
of the choice but I've been using the
honey extension for like maybe two years
and it's the best thing ever best thing
ever
okay so I when I'm shopping online I
shop at Alexa for azar revolve has honey
it's a free tool that connects to your
computer browser it scans the internet
anytime you shop online looking for
sales discounts coupon codes that way
when you're about to check out like
magic it'll automatically apply the best
promo code like it'll you see the line
it's literally mad
every single promo card aligned and
gives you the highest that sometimes I
get free shipping sometimes I get 50%
off it's the craziest thing and I truly
love it next time you're getting ready
to buy anything online install the honey
extension first make sure you're really
getting the lowest price available you
can add honey for free join honey calm /
toast that's join honey jo inh o ne
why.com / toast honey the smart shopping
assistant that helps save you time and
money save you money honey it's really
great I love that they're sponsoring the
toast because like I've truly been using
it the twisters told me about it know me
too it's like amazing and it's just like
so nice to see your price go down and I
used to like literally before I would
check out be like forever 21 promo oh my
god I always just do that what was a
freaking stupid web site called I don't
know England I know a liner he's like it
just gives you a million promo codes
that don't that don't work yeah well but
now honey does work I can't believe like
Taylor Swift doesn't have to use promo
codes you know what I mean I wonder if
she's like it I actually wonder this a
lot it she like ever swipes her credit
card no right like what does she pay for
likeness she definitely pays for it but
I don't think she acts actively swipes
her credit card cuz all the clothes that
she wears like even her pajamas like art
like stylists like did you just bring it
to the house they charge her account
there's no physical swiping but she pays
for a lot of stuff yeah I mean I'm sure
but like did she even have one you know
it's to have a wallet she deftly has a
black card oh definitely has a black
because she has a private jet Republic
bought the private jet and she's like
deaf like an Amex like Queen yes
everything you know net points cuz like
what does she do points where she was in
trouble
no but exactly so I'm sure she has a ton
of points you know I mean she doesn't
fly commercial I'm just saying racking
up points yeah yeah yeah I just feel
like at some point you're like too rich
for points yeah I mean you're too rich
to use points I just want to say like
from the time that I met the points guy
till now like I had truly changed so
much I got a first class trip to Israel
for five dollars and 60 cents with my
points that's so scared and I was really
proud Brian helped me through the whole
thing
that's insane yeah it was really great
I'm really proud of myself and for me
and Ben he was five dollars total or
five dollars each okay each drama queen
okay she jumped into the next story is
there anything else you want to say
about yesterday's like a minute no I'm
not done
I don't know I don't know now I'm
nervous
she just looked so amazing so radiant
she we haven't really gotten a lot from
her makes my lamb tail oh we've got no
all we've got in these like little posts
that we have to like dissect this was
like just bow blow just like on a silver
platter enjoy yeah okay I chose this
next story specifically for you because
it's an E roundup of sudden goodbyes how
TV shows like Riverdale have responded
to the shocking deaths of their
irreplaceable stars because it's almost
time to say but goodbye to Fred Andrews
over a month after the world lost the TV
icon with the sudden and tragic passing
of Luke Perry
on March 4th due to complications from a
massive stroke he'd suffered in his home
days prior wow that's a long sentence
the time has come for the last episode
of the Riverdale he ever filmed quote
this week this week's Riverdale is the
last episode Luke filmed creator Roberto
Reiter Ross tweeted on Monday he
continued as always friends and parting
words of wisdom to our ji a beautiful
true moment between a father and son
wish these scenes could go on forever he
has previously taken to Twitter in the
recent weeks since Luke's passing to pay
tribute to the beloved actor but now
they do a roundup real and we don't know
how Luke Perry is going to I wonder I
think I'm just like but here's like a
roundup of people who died while they
were on television like in cheers
Nicolas Cal Stano was cast as coach
Ernie on the NBC sitcom chairs he'd
already been diagnosed with a heart
disease which had been exacerbated by
his alcoholism
by season 3 his health had worsened and
he'd noticeably lost weight though he
kept the severity of the matter a secret
shortly after Christmas he was admitted
to the hospital due to water in his
lungs after two weeks day he was
released from the hospital okay just I
literally have no idea who that is he
appeared in the season finales cold-open
through the use of discarded footage his
last full episode was filmed in 1984
aired in 1985 his character's absence
that the rest of the season was either
explained away through jokes or not
acknowledged I scared Fred Andrews might
just not be acknowledged or they'll say
he like went to like wherever Molly
Ringwald books or something I don't know
they're definitely not gonna read recast
him I think I don't know they'll
probably touch on it for sure because I
feel him that well then there also is
the example most contemporary example of
Finn in glee so when Cory Monteith sadly
passed away from an accidental overdose
in 2013 after years of struggles with
substance abuse
he was weeks away from
beginning work on the fifth season of
Glee so they kind of had not that this
is an ideal situation at all but like it
was ideal in the sense that he finished
out a season and they opened the fifth
season with his death of being like he
just like Finn himself died yeah and all
the characters mourned it as Finn but
also as Cory and I kind of loved that oh
my god it was the saddest episode ever
live it was so powerful and at least
like the show that he like grew upon and
like really like became famous on got to
acknowledge his life and devote a whole
episode to it I thought it was such a
like a staple of a character that like
they had to have done something yeah and
like all of the emotions were so raw was
like they were all it was like when they
cried they were wasn't saying no I mean
like Leah Michelle singing make you feel
my love and I'll write up the classroom
and it was it was honestly like it was
too much you know like thinking about it
I could cry Naya Rivera singing die
young uh not die young that's Kesha
The Band Perry yes if I die young there
and she couldn't even finish it cuz she
was crying so much and they opened it
with seasons of love and then it was
called the quarterback the quarterback
episode just like such a powerful
episode and I feel like I mean Ryan
Murphy's a genius and I just love
everything really is a genius but that
was really like the perfect way and this
is like something that happens like
where people who are on TV shows old or
young like they die while it's oh yeah
and there's like no perfect way but I
think that that kept asone was the best
way but they're not gonna do that first
so what do you think they're gonna do I
don't know like with and I don't watch
up after what's going on um like he was
in jail yeah but I was not in jail
anymore now it's like a whole like other
thing with like there's another like
girl gang in the farm and Cheryl's part
of the farm now and so is Kevin and
whole thing sorry oh by the way if
you're behind and but the bread in the
past few episodes like really hasn't
been that integral he's just there for
like a side conversation every now and
then with Archie like when he like needs
advice or something so really he's like
us with us age yes so it really won't be
that hard I think to write Emacs it's
not like he has like a like when he was
gonna run when he was running for mayor
that would have been difficult right
that's not what's going on right now so
I it won't be too hard it's just like
more of a matter of like what are we
gonna do because like he needs parents
yeah oh that's true so it's Molly Molly
was about to might become a regular get
signed on for a few more episodes for
sure that would make sense like he does
need parents right how by the way and
Josie and RT r dating Josie and Archie
you know what I like Josie now but like
I will never get past her in season 1
being so mean about her singing like you
know like be like when Archie wants to
like to learn how to write songs and
like she was being such a bully like oh
my god such a bully but the Heather's
episode oh my god honestly like that
would've been enough for you to stop
watching Joey no dad yeah I would have
done their eyes oh it was bad the
Heather's episode I mean like I enjoyed
it but he's like so cringy like I could
just only imagine you watching and Cole
Sprouse say I was gonna say I saw a clip
of Cole's breasts sticking and I was
truly shook to my life they don't know
it was really crazy because he says in
every single interview he's like I
didn't see him for Disney like I'm not
singing like now I made it this far but
I guess like a lily asked you know and
Lily sang - well yeah but Joey sings
yeah and the girls just like have a good
voice and no I think it was like a
requirement that like each of them had
to be able to sing someone but hold the
tool when you were in high school at
your graduation had a solo live you had
a solo and I unfortunately didn't make
it to your high school graduation
because I was that I was flown to LA to
film an episode of candidly Nicole with
Nicole Richie
Nicole Richie and it sprouted my
friendship into Karrueche and honestly I
have no regrets like I'm sorry and I did
you I'd made something I made a call
film of the material terrible i brewed
okay like the fact that you still Harbor
resentment is like why you're a freak
but I'm the only thing I'm upset about
is that you had a solo and in the climb
in terms of like the family and like
talents
Olivia's always had like a fine like
good voice like Olivia was in her play I
have always had like the voice of an
angel and like you were just like this
like weirdo like who like never really
sang and but I had solos and everything
at my zimmer yeah okay but I don't know
like what your voice sounds like like no
but you're not about to have it happen
but yeah like you won't sing in public
like please no did you sing with you you
could like Shadle II like have an
amazing voice and we would never know
don't you worry I don't I even taking
voice lessons oh please now please if
you think I don't do for you in the
privacy of our own home I'm definitely
not gonna do it what if the toasters
like all fall even Instagram we get you
to a hundred thousand followers no no no
if I could snap my face yeah I don't
know this is too on the spot I'm
sweating okay but if I could snap my
fingers and give you a hundred thousand
followers would you sing
probably no no never better man
no being annoying I know I'm probably
come on nextdoor 85 okay well we're
wrapping that up very sad so this week
was the last episode with Fred Andrews
or last week tonight decide to tune in
no but you know that every single
episode now is dedicated to him it's
like so sad ever after every episode
ends it comes in big letters in memory
of Luke Perry and then his like years Oh
for the rest of the season I mean for us
in series oh that's sweet yeah that's
that's a nice day I like when people do
things like that like in friends which
whether we should talk about be oh we
have to talk about friends because since
you last saw Margaret roast she has now
been converted to a friends fan by me
but they never addressed 911 even though
it was like I know like it the show was
on during 9/11 it was like the most New
York show ever and they never addressed
it which part of me thinks it's like
nice like it was such a horrible time
like people were talking about it all
the time it's nice to escape and just
watch television and I'm one of those
people who believes that like world
tragedy is like should stay out of
entertainment cuz it's supposed to be
this like escapism but at the same time
like it really was a psychotic New York
show in the fact that they didn't
address it was like upsetting but I
guess the episode that aired directly
after 9/11 was dedicated to the people
of New York
look at that it's something you could
have easily missed I wonder if I've
gotten there you might not have cuz it's
later seasons oh no I haven't but also
they didn't address any anything with
9/11 insects and City either what sex me
and Jackie's have spoken about this I
don't know if Sex in the City was on in
2001 I think it was hold on let me check
I don't have the comments up here I'm in
the city yes it was on from more about
this show oh yeah you're right 1998 to
2004 yeah they didn't yeah
I wonder why I wonder why to you but
it's like I get why but I also get why
not you know yeah I mean but so he wakes
that decision you know I like if I write
or Ross or it would be like the creator
Patrick I know Patrick's Partridge
Channel star Patrick Starr no that's
sorry Patrick
what's his name Darren star Darren star
and Patrick King who the heck's at the
second one of yeah it would have been
their decision so I
say they won yeah nothing interests on
teh okay third story is one that me and
Jackie actually like have not spoken
about just because like for a lot of
reasons but I thought we would talk
about it with you because you at one
point in your life where Britney Spears
is number one fan
oh my god I had a Britney Spears
impersonator at like my birthday and I
used to have this ginormous like banner
of her in my room and I could kiss it
every night before I went to bed and you
also had a picture of Britney on all
your birthday cakes yeah I was like
obsessed there which is so weird cuz I
don't even like remember that do you
know what I mean like I don't rember
feeling that way about Britney Spears
and like right now do you feel like you
feel so disconnected from that Britney
like it's not the same oh yeah like I I
forget that they're the same person
but there's a lot going on the memory
hashtag free Britney Britney Spears
breaks her silence amid the allegations
that she's being held against her will
she says don't believe everything so
Britney Spears says all is well and just
needs quote time to do the singer booked
her silence on Instagram on Tuesday
sharing a video reassuring her fans that
she's in good health and mid allegations
that she's being held against her will
at a health facility hi guys
just checking in with all of you who
have been concerned about me all as well
my family has been going through a lot
of stress and anxiety lately so I just
needed time to deal but don't worry I'll
be back very soon she also posted a
lengthy caption addressing the recent
rumors circulating about her health and
her family this is her caption I just
wanted to say hi because things are
being said that I've just gotten out of
control with three exclamation points
Wow three exclamation points the rumors
death threats to my family and my team
and just so many crazy things being said
I'm trying to take a moment for myself
but everything that's happening is just
making it harder for me don't believe
everything you read in here these fake
emails everywhere we're crafted by Sam
lefty years ago I did not write them he
was pretending to be me and
communicating with my team with a fake
email address my situation is unique but
I promise I'm doing what's best in this
moment you may not know this about me
but I'm strong oh and stand up for what
I want your love and dedication is
amazing but what I need right now was a
little bit of privacy to deal with other
things that life is soaring my way if I
could do that I would forever if you
could do that I would forever be
grateful love you okay so the new Sam
one of her former managers the theory
now is that like so she stopped her
residency and she was admitted to a
mental health facility and they people
are saying these against her well yeah
just like things that they're seeing on
Instagram like some paparazzi photos
like people have just so
mounted to the fact that she is put in
this facility against her will by like
her managers and her family and her
dad's specifically um and I don't know a
lot about Brittany
but just like I hate when people jump to
conclusions based off what they see on
Instagram like and paparazzi photos like
it's all so fake and don't fake I just
feel like she's fine maybe she's not
fine but I don't you know held against
her yeah she's not fine but she's got a
gun but she's working on it and that
should just be an effort maybe she's
okay but she's not fine it cuz they wait
sorry it's okay I purposely didn't join
any here but no now you brought it up
now it's making some conscious but I
sing if you like ten minutes ago when
you sing so I thought to read listen cuz
I wasn't like listening to your voice I
wasn't like I can just tell you right
now it's not good is that enough for you
today a new I guess um like I just think
she's fine I think she's fine in the
world is like [ __ ] their pants I'm
like these like hashtag Britney time I'm
on in free Britney like she's good guys
know she got the 9-1-1 she's totally
fine like no she's not totally fine but
she's getting help like think about it
she has been on a non-stop like working
tour album show tour I saw this coming I
think since she was [ __ ] 16 like she
had a breakdown already and and she's
better than she but and she was I just I
I understand her brutally like what had
happened everyone was hitting their
pants but like I get it man we do not
the shaving of the head but like and
there's so many in there people people
in her life who definitely like control
her money and like her career and it's
frustrating but I think like in present
moment like it's just best that she's
not fully in control and she just like
takes a little bit of a backseat no I
agree I think that God willing she'll be
fine and like everyone needs to like
chill the [ __ ] out
totally and stop just like making
judgments about what you see like it's
so annoying like people think they know
everything about someone because they
follow them on Instagram you know do you
mean no hardly like you know nothing Jon
Snow nothing Jon Snow justice Fergie
grid now she could have killed you twice
and she did it
yeah but he could have killed her back
and he should have Margo sorry I mean
just like that scene of them in the cave
and when she died she said we never
should have left that cave emember like
the worst Irish I know but she's a
funniest thing I did it that time Q&A
one of the questions like who's your
celebrity
freaking love drive knows and this girl
TMZ she's freaking out she's like who it
says she doesn't want to eat my throat
she's like who is this I'm freaking out
he looks just like my boyfriend like
why'd you put up a picture of my
boyfriend and she sent me pictures of
her boyfriend I'm like she's dating tour
man and it was the freakiest thing ever
like no beard but the picture I put up
of torment didn't have a beard yeah I
thought that that was like a look-alike
when at first and then I saw the bearded
boy when I went to go Google search a
picture of torment what's his name I
don't know he's brave he's brave the
movie brave when I went to go find a
picture of him like all the news
articles like you're not gonna believe
what torment looks like without his
beard and it's true like he looks like a
Disney Prince now I love him so much
like if the b-girl here is the bigger
I've always had blue eyes it's like I
don't know why all of a sudden I guess
he always was like that great but he has
been so funny this season he's been so
funny like I'm obsessed with tormund
know I'm obsessed determinacy said that
he got big drinking the milk out of a
jam yeah swipes teeth teeth Deepti I was
in class yesterday and it's just boring
a three-hour class about power and some
of it really it's so boring yet you're
always fighting talking about Game of
Thrones and it's all about power so my
entire class just went in I Game of
Thrones sharing theories and who their
favorite characters were it's just so
interesting how stupid some people are
is you're like you could do your final
thesis on Game of Thrones oh I asked if
I could do my final theses about Taylor
Swift and he said it's already been done
and it wasn't that great because it's
not that challenging and I was like it's
not trouble I was like how challenging
at all but she is powerful she is she is
but that's why it's not challenging like
she's powerful by know but like I could
do a deep to know honestly it wouldn't
be hard for me is what his point was
right he was just beating you dick yeah
essentially okay so but like we were
sending our well wishes and thoughts to
Britney Spears yes essentially okay next
story just want the best for her and
maybe like she should like retire is an
interesting factoid that I found to be
well interesting from the Daily Mail
jeopardy contestant becomes the only
second
becomes only second in history to win
more than a million dollars during fork
during his 14 weeks shriek streak his
name is Jane Holzhauer he's 34 years old
and he won 118 thousand dollars Tuesday
taking his overall winnings to a million
dollars the professional gambler from
Las Vegas has already sent five one-day
records he now wants to match the 74
game two and a half million dollar
streak of Ken Jennings in 2004 so so he
seems a professional gamer and he's
smart
I guess so if you play dangerous combo
if you play and you win like that takes
you over to the next day and the next
day and today most people do like one
two three days but he's now on a five
day streak and he's over a million
dollars that's crazy I want to see what
he looks like oh he's a cutie oh he's
like a cute little nerd vibe you know
but he's also a professional gambler
yeah wait look he's like he definitely
can get it I wonder if he has a
girlfriend he will now go now oh he's so
cute yes he's at a million sixty one
thousand five hundred and fifty so when
you say he's doing this like for the two
and a half mil thing like could he
technically lose the rat like you know
you you you still gather the million but
he needs to keep winning everyday
because they have new chick the other
two contestants are new every day
right so he needs to keep beating until
his overall amount it's two and a half
million oh my I mean he technically I
think could lose it all right no I don't
think you're allowed to gamble with the
previous winner oh so it's like after
each episode you got your winnings then
you kind of ish start at zero at the
beginning of the episode yeah you're
right and then if you win again it adds
to your previous oh that's crazy but
like after taxes he's not that much well
where do they film I guess with it's
where he lives like if he lives when we
were in South Carolina I was looking up
the tax bracket like the highest tax
bracket is 7% is that how it works with
the lottery - if you win in South
Carolina or something you get tax the 7%
or you get taxed like actually that's
income tax I don't know if you would
consider like lottery winnings income
and also you have too many federal tax
and the federal is always more so hmm
difficult difficult I don't think I
could literally ever be on an episode of
Jeopardy like I've watched and there's
maybe one question that I like have
heard of the people I didn't even get it
right but I've heard of the book you
know and it's like
I'll watch one time and
one answer that they don't know and I'll
be like are you [ __ ] kidding I'm so
stupid
then then again it's like I don't know
any other one and like if they do the
Taylor Swift themed jeopardy I could do
it I could do it I think I think too but
it's like there's like there's some
things I don't know you know like when
people asked like those stupid questions
like like dates of things like when did
but boob uh come out like I don't know
things like that I used to know stuff
about like Montana the people who go on
Jeopardy like who are they is there a
book daddy like flashcards mm-hmm for
sure it's like you just have to know
everything about everything exactly
that's why I asked but I don't think
they would give you a study guide not
how it works so you just have to
automatically just know everything I
love Alex Shrek meet you and I hope he
like is doing okay I know me too I'm
like I think about him a lot me too like
I'm not ready
well I hope this guy James can take it
all the way and like made me find
himself a nice wife if he's not already
married hopefully he's already married
now he won't know if they're in it for
the money or not did you also see the
guy who won the 768 million dollar
Powerball but like took a month to come
forward so like it was a huge press like
um what's a called uh or press
conference yesterday kids give him
giving his statement saying hey I
couldn't believe it he was like scared
that and so it's like it's all about
what I don't know it's a little weird
I'm sure they're checking it out like
hard yeah but like but he was so cute
like if he did win like I really hope
it's real because it what is he like you
know man no he's a cute yeah he's 24
like oh he's never gonna have to work
another day in his life and he's just
like his from Wisconsin and he was like
I just felt good about ten dollars worth
of tickets and I just checked at the
last one
and he's like when I got the first he's
think I've done it before so like I
never get the first number like somebody
get like the Powerball number or like
the fifth number but one of my tickets I
won four dollars and I was like freaking
out cuz like that never happens
and then for the other one like I got
the first number and like I was freaking
out because I do never bet the first
number and then I got the second and
third and he was like I literally
couldn't believe it I'm just looking a
little confused as to why it took him so
long right but I understand maybe
waiting a few days because like you want
to wait for it to die down and like not
have someone like jump you please take
it but now a month is a little weird but
like they'll-they'll figured out where
is he from Wisconsin I just feel like
it'll be really good for him know that
could you imagine I bought a lot lottery
ticket like twice in
I've never like even gotten a semblance
of clothes - oh my god wouldn't be in
bed and we're in Chicago no no um where
did me and Ben go for a show oh oh no
ismenia in Columbus or Cincinnati we
went out to lunch oh yes yeah and we
went to this toy store that was like a
prank toy so I only had like they got
like silly putty got like all this stuff
and as we were checking out there were
fake lottery tickets that were like
automatically guaranteed to win $10,000
yeah and we were sitting in the lobby
with my former manager and we like
pretended to do it we were literally
being actresses I was like I went oh my
god it was so much that's a great prank
it is a great but we should have like
gotten stuff but to take home when the
guy was like it's a fake a lottery
ticket I like literally didn't
understand I'm like so you win like I
was so confused it was really sad yeah
it was kind of me before we deliver our
fifth and final story and then jump into
a Taylor Swift like Q&A that we got from
this Dinis fifties group I'd like to
tell everyone about another sponsor of
the toasted Squarespace okay and you're
now getting a job like building your
resume you need a website by the way do
I hear like everyone who's applying for
jobs any time but someone applies for a
job for me they'll send me their reps
and I'm like are you an artist or no it
has links to like their resume and their
Instagram it's really interesting just
another thing I need and you're going on
an interview did you print out your
resume six times
okay maybe that's why I'm wearing this
by the way okay so Squarespace is all in
one domains websites online stores
marketing tools from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business or promote yourself
Margo and they have a new feature for
email campaigns you can say more sell
more stand out in any inbox with
Squarespace email campaigns they're all
inland platform makes it easy to unify
your brand voice from your homepage to
your emails consistent content from
website to email powerful editing tools
to make it your own so if you can head
to squarespace.com slash toast you get a
free trial when you're ready to launch
use the offer code toast to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain we started using Squarespace with
our camp choice website which is still
being worked on and I just feel like
it'd be really good for your brand oh
damn I might have to do it like a
portfolio with a headshot
oh my god I don't have a headshot I need
to get a headshot I just took new
headshots and it was honestly like the
hardest day of my life no they learn to
look pretty face on joining in an
awkward setting no but not even that
just like a lot of times it's like when
you're
this like this this is cute for me but
like this it's not you know I need mean
so like getting a good picture like that
is truly I had Chuck can be the side
profile to like if you want it like
Olivia's headshot it's like my LinkedIn
pictures a picture that like we took on
vacation a hundred years ago what is it
it's just like me at dinner like but
like it's like and it's like no I'm
covered and it's normal but it's like I
look so young no LinkedIn pictures are
truly so awkward it's so awkward but I
didn't know that LinkedIn is like such a
thing like yeah I like now I'd like been
spending my time on LinkedIn like people
like update their status like Olivia
updates her status like you just like
and like people I always see like my
friends like liking things and I'm doing
like I didn't know that this is like a
platform people go on like I have a
LinkedIn like from a hundred years ago I
know I checked it what does it say I'm
absolute like nothing relevant right now
there are people who are like LinkedIn
influencers a friend of mine used to
work for Ryan Serhant who's on million
dollar was saying at her job was
literally just accepting people on
LinkedIn because he's like a link to an
influencer interesting I haven't hit 500
yet you haven't
I got like picky cuz like it's like
sometimes I'm like just don't want to
connect with some people why do you care
I don't know you're free I know I'm okay
so our fifth and final stories from
paper magazine and it's Taylor Swift
stands give us their predictions for for
26 so paper magazine spoke to a lot of
like people who run to us with fan
accounts Twitter accounts and what they
think is gonna happen so let's go
through the person who runs TS updates
New York we believe that Taylor will
release the brand new lead single from
her seventh album released the music
video for the song and released the
album title and artwork she'd possibly
put it up for pre-order too we believe
it's music we don't think it's anything
else even if it's something else it will
still come with music her team wouldn't
spend money on promotional billboards in
8 countries for music not to be involved
agreed but I don't think all that's
happening on Brian oh I don't know if
we'll get album cover in title but
definitely lead song and maybe a video
and maybe a video or or she's gonna have
the video premiere at the VMAs oh my god
I'm gonna be there that's my call this
is from Taylor's with facts hmm for me
she's teasing her ts7 album single Plus
music video other than album singer
music video maybe marriage that is the
worst call Taylor would never Taylor
doesn't feel like she owes us an update
on her life you want to know why she
doesn't it's because her fans are so
amazing her fans there are a lot of fans
who feel in
titled like I'm your fan I support you I
demand to know everything about you
personally professionally career-wise
and tailors with chance I don't have
that sort of entitlement and she never
feels like she has to give updates like
I broke up at this person me and this
person are together like when she breaks
up with someone like I don't even know
how we know right and also like Taylor
Swift fans I get mad when like paparazzi
takes pictures of her on vacation
because it value her privacy just as
much as she was just like how much they
respect ya this is from swiftness 13
my guess is Taylor will drop the lead
single from ts7 and based on the visuals
from her Instagram possibly the music
video - there's finally some links
between the visuals so I'm guessing
they're either album visual work album
artwork or they're from a video I think
the videos not an album artwork because
that's not what I want for album artwork
we all know the Taylor loves to drop
hints by hints and clues my clues as you
can see there are seven palm trees on
the tree post it represents her past
seven albums her past albums and the
other one is her current album she's
dropping the album on the 26 because
Taylor loves to drop album dates in the
20s except for reputation I don't think
that's necessarily I don't think that's
true either
what do you think ts7 will sound like I
think I really really not because I
wanted to but I really think it's gonna
be like country pop so far we have bets
placed on retro 90s probably disco or
synth-heavy pop it'll be most similar to
1989 but still different with Taylor you
never know what you're gonna get and
you're not gonna get the same thing
twice we think nostalgia will be a theme
or like memories or something along
those lines maybe stuff about her
childhood - or just general reminiscing
and obviously love songs about Jo I
really hope it's not disco or well
something interesting and that really
sparked the debate with Jackie yesterday
was I had said that I think ts7 will be
a lot of music that ts6 was supposed to
be right and that a couple years ago
before Taylor Kanye whole thing happened
Taylor was getting ready to release a
new album because it had been over a
year since 1989 and as she was gearing
up like making the proper preparations
this whole thing happened she like went
into a hole and hid and like wrote all
this music about Kanye and her
reputation and released that verse
because it was something she had to say
but she still has this cachet of music
and Jackie was saying that she didn't
feel like it would be authentic - to
Taylor and saying that like she didn't
she wouldn't have shown any growth if
she's releasing old music which is so
stupid because she just started
performing better man when better man is
an old song okay here's my opinion I
don't think that the entire album would
be
the old music I think of anything it
would be a mix of the two and I get that
but I wouldn't really mind because I
still do want to hear the songs that she
made back then so if she doesn't if she
doesn't put them out now she's never
gonna do it so I wouldn't mind if I
three or four are from by the way I
really hope that they are because I
don't want them to get lost like me to
never hear them again this whole Kanye
thing it ends up in us losing some
premium Taylor Swift songs like I'll be
pissed
I'd be pissed no and also like I feel
like those songs are definitely like so
good cuz like that was a lot of drama
with like Calvin and all them so it's
like she deserves to put that out there
and we deserve to hear it but I don't
think the whole album is gonna be old
but like what's what's the difference if
two songs or three songs are old and
it's gonna be like it's really not the
baby deal let her do her own thing
leave her alone leave her it's like I
trust her creative to use accept she's
releasing doesn't have to be about the
last year of her life because like she
wrote their songs what I said yesterday
is there are songs on reputation that
you could argue or about John Mayer you
know any I'm mayor yeah and that was ten
years ago yeah you know what I mean I
think she has this cachet of music lucky
she probably has a notebook with over
500 songs that she could just pick him
write an album at any time that's like
so like babe was just like a piece of
dirt on the floor that she pulled out
it's like okay so I did a post insanity
Swifties which is our if you listen to
our podcast you know that you are
eligible to get into the morning trust
Facebook group which is really big and
there's a long line to get in and once
you get in you're eligible for subgroups
and one of our subgroups is this teeny
Swifty's and it's just for like it's
really a safe space because I can save
even the main group is like always
talking [ __ ] about Taylor and it's just
like it weighs heavy on my heart so I
did a master post asking for like
questions about Taylor things we want to
talk about so I'm just gonna run through
a Lee gag Lyon speak now is her greatest
album changed my mind I'm not changing
your mind cuz I couldn't agree more I've
been saying this for years for years
Speak Now is the best album long late is
the best song okay maybe that could be
argued with all too well but Speak Now
is truly so good
and it tells so many stories oh my god I
agree I'm not changing your mind Ally I
really like teeter between which are her
best albums because I really feel like
read fearless speak now and 1989 are all
fantastic
I understand but if you take them one by
one like in red there she has some
bangers she has grace all too well but
there's a lot of wrongs that are like
yeah like yes I agree begin again but
and then in speak now like honestly
every single song is good like you can't
name one that's like that's true you
can't name one that's man I feel that
way about 1989 as well and fearless
though okay I understand it's mating
forever in always hey Steven Hayes you
belong with me like so many bangers yeah
oh yeah but just like speak now has
holds a special place in my heart maybe
it's because we watched that the speak
now live concert like every day in high
school and those are my trans for maybe
I think and maybe that's why it's like
their aegis and the weirdest part about
how I fell into like Taylor Swift
obsession is when we were in high school
there used to be a Radio Shack around
the corner from our house like remember
in Radio Shack I remember it and mom was
always sending me on errands to [ __ ]
radio check for like things for the
house phone it was so annoying yeah and
I went and like she gave me her credit
card till I get some like [ __ ]
[ __ ] for the house and I was like
pissed that I had to go and at the
register
there was a DVD of the Taylor Swift tour
and I was like you know what she made me
run this errand I'm buying myself the
DVD and I thought it means our lives day
after school we watched it every day on
repeat every weekend like and that is
really how I fell into like being such a
big fan of for me too because like I can
honestly say like when fearless and like
all that stuff came out I liked the
songs but like I didn't really like pay
attention to the woman behind the song
great like Satori or any of that but
when Speak Now came out like my life was
truly changed just honestly like the
lesson here is do errands for your mom
yeah I could go to Radio Shack okay to
yell Ashley what is your favorite tour
of Taylor's tour well I was very upset
that I didn't make it to reputation tour
because I was in Israel and it's just
something that I have to live with for
the rest of my life but that being said
I still don't know that it would have
been my favorite 1989 was just yeah
really 1989 or I just was watching a
journey to fearless and fearless is
really like it was such a moment where
she was like so young yeah and it's so
impressive but I think 1989 was the most
impressive because of what she did to
her own music like I thought 1989 was
great but after watching it on tour and
then watching the video 100 times like I
really thought it was even better than
originally like what she did to out of
the woods what she did to out of the
wood because went out of the way
came out I would have put it on my least
favorites top five worst songs me too
and when she remastered it I want to say
it is maybe her best song no it's too
soon and like she performed that also at
the program it's like I've watched her
performance 800 times so uh there's like
a big theory people thinking that what
she's teasing is like a remastered album
oh and I wouldn't be mad I wouldn't be
mad because I do want to at some point
in my life get those like the remastered
but I I feel I got something you do like
at the end of your career yeah or it's
like not the end Margo it's like her
what she did on 1989 tour with enchanted
and wildest dreams okay and what she did
with long live in New Year's Day which
by the way were like one of the two of
my favorite songs it's like she's like
Margo I'm doing this for you you know
she has the perfect way of like blending
her own song I'm even what to call bad
blood and should have said no oh that
was so so good anything out of all those
enchanted wildest dreams this is the
best yeah I mean hi did you notice that
last night she didn't do the high note
and what in shake it off oh you know I'm
Michael I they want shake it off because
I really don't so you inches I guess
Oh do it I love that part I know but I
think it's just because it's like too
small a room for some totally and like
they're not worthy yeah
top five Taylor songs of all time and
then top five worse okay let's agree on
the top five okay
long live in l2l first year well and
living all too well New Romantics okay
um love story it's it's such a good song
when I was hearing it last night like I
was like this is frickin banger okay
love story
and the fifth one should come from
speaking now long live was speaking oh
okay yeah Oh enchanted
Oh the reason why I love enchanted so
much it's like the song is great but the
premise behind it is so lovely like she
was at a party and like she met the lead
singer of Owl City or one of those band
liked him and she like had a little
crush em but she just thought he was
like so nice and they like had like a
little connection like nothing ever came
of it but like she was just so enchanted
to meet him he wrote he wrote a rebuttal
song like being like it was just chance
to meet you
what like yeah okay so the fifth song I
didn't know I feel like the fish should
maybe be from reputation no not a one no
yeah that's not one of them is like it's
like like maybe like a style blank space
no please
okay fine no okay whatever type of state
of grace Oh state of grace oh my god
sorry their top five worst shake it off
shake it off
look what you made me do really yes I
bigmar got that all right you can you
can get that one um oh oh I don't okay
come in with the rain okay yeah how do
you feel about how you get the girl love
it okay I love it nothing on 1989 is
gonna be on the worst list okay nothing
from speed now either no and I can't
like something from red oh for sure the
woman cheering OH
everything is just I totally agree and I
know this is controversial but I do not
like to begin again but it's definitely
not like the worst it's not like just
like it's a fine song yeah there's
honestly I've won more the lucky one I
like that song there's a lot of stuff I
mean I know it's also one of my best
songs
so cute the best day oh my god totally
you know what's really one of her best
songs that's so cute Ronen know for sure
but ours and I just realized everything
guy have a someday gonna be gone how sad
is that
yeah it's so true like every now and
then like when you're just living your
life you realize like one day everyone's
gonna be dead yeah let's talk about that
I know but like what's the fifth one I
don't know I have one what I did
something bad yeah it's not like that
it's not great it's just good um what is
a favorite Taylor lyric like one that
really resonated with you yeah we know
we know what the moms do well
oh I mean all of all to all of them but
there but there are there lyrics that
you live by like mine I have two lyrics
from new breathing I mean New Romantics
that like changed my life like because
maybe I could build a castle out of all
the bricks they threw at me yeah you do
real live by that one and also people
throwing rocks at things that shine but
this doesn't spot for me I can't think
of one like right now another lyric that
really resonated with me not personally
just like really made me realize how
good of a songwriter she is is handsome
you're a mansion with the view because I
didn't really understand what that meant
but then someone made me realize you're
a mansion with a view so you're
beautiful on the outside and the inside
how green I just got actual check I know
that's crazy
honestly every lyric in long-lived cuz
like long live I don't know why I love
long live so much it's just like it says
so many things it's like it could be
about you and your friends just like
it's about her in her pants no I know
but I'm talking about if you want to
related your life because I don't have
fans
can you discuss Casey unfollowing Taylor
I didn't know that I'm feeling I didn't
know that I don't know if she ever
followed her but Rustin just covered all
too well so why would he do that if
there's a weird thing because went it
when Kacey Musgraves released a pageant
material there's a song of the boys club
and people think it's in dig at you know
Taylor because another gear in a big
machine so they think it's like Big Ben
big machine like is Taylor's was
chillers label some people thought it
was digging hurt but the song was called
boys club so I don't know why I could
I don't think so no but Casey it's just
not like friendly like she's not like
into being friends with other country or
whatever so great they obviously respect
the hell out of her because Rustin
released in all too well covers so I'm
not digging I'm not getting I'm not
supporting them claim it they're like I
just don't think they really have
anything to do with each other but I'm
sure like they listen to each other and
like babbling Taylor it's like it's not
like they're friends if it's just like
you would follow celebrities you know
that's true and like hasn't follow her
talk about how you feel about the level
of secrecy and lack of transparency that
occurs with Taylor as opposed to other
pop stars do you think it makes her more
addicting like kind of seriousness I
don't really mind it actually kind of
liked it better because it's like ariana
grande like post every single thing she
doesn't like now it's just I kind of
find it annoying yeah but I still follow
her but it's like with Taylor it's like
she just like gives us what she wants us
to hear and then what we need to serve
all they need to see but whatever and
like if that's what she thinks and also
like she is hurt her fame is so out of
control that if this is what you need to
do to sketch some semblance of privacy
like I'm fine with I couldn't agree more
so when did you guys start becoming
obsessed with her so I think we answered
that like we were really like from the
beginning also like know I remember I
used to when I lived in the purple room
I used to literally listen to teardrops
are together oh yes and that music video
you drink all the time in our song yeah
oh my god our song like we really were
there from day one and that way yeah
everywhere I never really realized
that's what makes me like really proud
I wish we were like those people though
who had like pecan to her concert but
you know what it was it was like and I
was just saying this when I did my
Instagram live it was not like when I
was a kid like you know those kids who
like just like their parents like buy
them whatever they want yeah like I had
no control over what I could get do you
know did used to have the iTunes
password tickets to a concert like oh
yeah if I went to go to a concert like
it was just like no you know what I mean
I love that I wasn't given everything I
wanted to growing up cuz those kids are
monsters but like I there's a part of me
that like regrets never having gone to
the speaking outdoor do you know but
like honestly up to the Speak Now Tour
yeah we could have somehow finesse that
we could have never really finessed like
fearless like honestly we were so young
there was a rumored long before 1989
that was gonna be called roses and now
the merch she's wearing has roses on it
maybe this next album or single will be
called roses or different name of a
flower flowers seem to be like a flower
see I wouldn't mind that or lilies like
that's cute god I hope that's not the
name of the album no me too it's like a
little bit and okay I have a question
for you do you actually think that step
into the daylight and let it go will be
a lyric no me neither
step into the daylight and let it go was
one of those okay yeah she does like to
reuse because step into the daylight and
let it go was really like the the mantra
of this entire reputation like and this
is a transitional period for me yeah I
agree
tell us your favorite Taylor conspiracy
mine is that she used to leave her
apartment in those like luggage
equipment cases and I think it's totally
true I came up with a theory
remember the pregnancy one know that
when she took her year-and-a-half off
because she always said that like she
doesn't she know she have kids just
because like it would be really crazy
for the kid and like kind of annoying
for them and so when she took that
year-and-a-half off like what if she had
a kid and now with nobody would know who
her kid is or anything like that and she
could have a kid and have the joy of
being a mother but nobody knows the kid
is so the kid isn't tortured that was my
conspiracy theory interesting thank you
where will you be listening on 426
midnight Eastern in story your reaction
like you did with know we were on we
will be on the plane by the way you know
that we heard look well you made me do
together in the most yeah we weren't on
that like shuttle oh yeah anyway so we
will be on the plane to stagecoach but
thankfully JetBlue has great Wi-Fi and
streaming so sorry what to 9 o'clock it
be 9 o'clock
California time but we'll still be on
the plane well yeah we'll be like
preparing for when we land at 10:00 yeah
so no it'll be an hour before oh my god
okay look what are we gonna do we're
just gonna light it okay I want to make
a reaction video like in the bathroom
and we are out sitting next to each
other oh my god I paid $100 to move into
a middle seat to sit next to my sister
yay at extra legroom um wait what do you
think our most underrated song is
underrated song um I don't know it's
like I feel like the fandom is so on top
of it that like when they find you Jam
like right they exploit it you know none
of that right but just in general I
would say like new romantic new romantic
to cynics I was gonna say that it's not
under whatever the word was cuz baby
yeah it's the best oh I feel like like
Oh like a wonderland
yes Oh totally yeah um do you think her
and Harry Styles were a good match yes I
think about them all the time I think
they were horrible I think they were
great for each other and I think they
miss each other that's my theory what is
your favorite relationship of hers um
Harry or Kennedy mine is John Mayer like
and I know we never we never got to see
paparazzi pictures of them and like we
only know that they dated from the songs
but I like I totally get that moment she
was in like she was this up-and-coming
songwriter and if you ever watched a
youtube video like every time John Mayer
had said something nice about Taylor
Swift yeah because before they became
enemies and they dated they were writing
songs together they wrote half of my
heart together it's a good song and now
it went into oblivion and like now and
before that they were just like friends
who like we're writing together and he
they became like and it wasn't in the
age of instagrams like we didn't really
know about it but it's kind of how like
I know they were just like admirers of
each other and like when Taylor we got
an award he would be the one to give
it's like how Harry Styles and Stevie
Nicks are like yeah
weirdly friends so there was just like
this mutual like respect for each other
and it and it's like she was just like
this new comer and like he was like the
hot bad boy and like she got him and
like I'm sure she was just like so
excited about it yeah and like that it
didn't end up the way that she wanted
that he wasn't a better man was
upsetting but like I don't know there's
something about like I was so happy for
like you've liked you know what it's
like when you like something like older
and cooler oh my god totally like she
got him and like I was just I'm so happy
for and that's why I think he was like
really hard for her and that's why I
think a lot of her songs are about me to
just not even about him but just like
the way that he made her feel right um
and I also really loved her in Calvin
and I know that that was like a toxic
relationship for her and it ended really
badly so while it's going on like they
were pretty like she was just so cool
and normal like going to Vegas with the
ham girls like getting a table and like
not her boyfriend Bob like I loved it me
too
I just loved what she gave us from that
time I don't know that I loved Calvin
but like yeah I agree with that um this
is like a hard question if Kim
Kardashian and Taylor were falling off
of a cliff who would you save I really
don't know I hate when people do this
like stop I mean they're not gonna be on
the cliff cuz they don't hang out
thoughts Idol Swift so that era that was
weird I didn't like it that was weird I
still don't get it
I just don't think he's cute like I'm
down for everything share him yeah like
there was so much that didn't make sense
um what do you think about Wendy
Williams saying she
/ Taylor I didn't even hear that
Margaret II took the words truly write
ever out of my mouth
the Selena Gomez of it all like they
have a weird friendship and they always
like had a true friendship but like
Taylor's really on the straight and
narrow and like doesn't [ __ ] around like
drink champagne for fun and Selena is is
not in a good place right so I feel like
their friendships weird I think their
friendships weird but I do think that
Taylor is like a very stable friend for
Selena yes I think it's rare and so I
think that while Selena like does have
her issues and Taylor doesn't I think
Taylor's has been a very good friend to
Selena and will continue to because like
Selena like has like issues and she's
not gonna just run away run away with
her friend eater yeah and I feel like
every time Julian is trying to get her
life together she hangs out with Taylor
I'm just thinking oh tell her all the
time do you support or dismiss the
notion that girls who blindly just like
Taylor Swift are not nice girls I
support it
no they just don't understand you know
it's so fresh they don't wanna
understand which means that they are not
understanding people which way that
they're just stubborn and annoying it's
like if you have no like interest and
even hearing the other side like I can't
like I just can't relate to when people
like okay when people like don't like
Taylor I literally asked them why right
and it has knobbly I'm willing to hear
the other side or not why they don't
like like why they don't think she's
everything people are like her voice
sucks and you know I can look like I
said a good part of being a real stan is
hearing all the good the bad the ugly
and while Taylor vocally is not
comparable so I can ariana grande like
what's most impressive to me about
Taylor is everything else in addition to
like she has a great voice but it's like
the songwriting and I Adrian the way she
makes people feel and it's like Ariana
Grande's voice is incredible and her
voice and her her songs make me you know
Bob but never once have I listened to an
ariana grande saw and felt like half the
feelings that I feel when I agree even
more Taylor Swift's worse so I agree so
it's like and trying to emulate that to
people who don't understand is so
frustrating but also some people might
just not care like they just might care
more so just about like a song that's
about that they can sing along to as
opposed to like taking the time to
listen to the lyrics and like understand
it's like they might not be mature
enough to understand how great Taylor is
and people just like hate celebrities
for no reasons and people
just love to hate people that everyone
loves so so true I just like I can't be
bothered
yeah I better things to do with my life
but you do that cuz everyone loves
beyoncé and you hate Beyonce it's not
that I don't hate Beyonce just like I
just like don't get it okay
that's fair but I think that she like is
an amazing dancer has an amazing like
don't get me wrong I understand it too
talent but it's not like attracted to
this is what she's having me yeah I have
like started to I mean like I appreciate
Beyonce so much like that video of her
in the back of the car from the HBO
documentary or her practicing listen oh
I didn't watch oh my god you guys watch
a video it's like from her HBO
documentary was just this one moment
where she was about to perform something
and she in the car she's on her laptop
and she's just playing listen and she's
practicing the de larix and I've never
heard anyone seeing better in my life
like it's the craziest thing and her
talent is so undeniable but I just don't
know but why can't people say that I
might tell her her talent is under that
eyeball you don't have to love everyone
that everyone loves right you can be
appreciated look I don't hate Beyonce
and every but I appreciate whatever does
in the world appreciates Beyonce even if
you don't like her her music they
appreciate it's like everyone either
with Taylor - either you're obsessed or
you hate her and it's so in a way I
agree I do I believe that Taylor she got
the same amount of respect that Beyonce
gets yeah but I think Beyonce deserves
that respect Oh Taylor does also know
totally and no and I'm not trying to pit
women against another woman like no
they're so different they're so
different and in their own right and
it's really impressive that like the two
of them are like the only artists
regardless of gender who like sell out
stadiums continuously yeah I would like
read they both hold records they're big
they're like with each other with their
records yeah it's great and I love that
and they're both fantastic
I just wish like a lot some like I just
wish people would respect Taylor like HS
upsets me you know I agree but then like
if everyone was respecting her and being
obsessive her that would be annoying
that's true I kind of liked that like
people don't like her it was like that
I'm special I agree
exactly I feel like I'm in on something
like special well this felt really good
to just like talk I feel lighter I feel
like I lost some weight um so here's
what's going on
tomorrow we will be a podcast only
episode because we are heading to
stagecoach and then Friday Saturday
Sunday we're going to be a stagecoach so
make sure to follow along on the morning
shows Instagram on our instagrams and
we're also gonna be filming a patreon
vlog for stagecoach which will be our
final episode of the month so make sure
to subscribe at patreon.com slash to
mourn a toast
so yes look out for tomorrow's episode
in the pod
and we will see you next week have an
amazing about you know cuz then me and
Jackie are going to the Billboard Music
Awards so we're flying to LA and then
today agai so we're gonna be doing
podcasts next week as much as we can
there'll be no live shows next week
until like Friday I think yeah okay cool
bye guys love you
you